and so as you can see we're going old
school today I'm doing this on a white
board my name is Todd Perry so you would
have seemed cool stuff about me but
roughly I just moved today to Berlin
from mattel Aviv I work at Citibank big
big bank lots of people lots of problems
in LLP we had problems with everything
Miroslav said so I think the biggest
takeaway should take from the talk is do
everything that he said because he's
absolutely right and once you get that
right you can start thinking about fancy
algorithms which is what I'm going to
talk about and so a bit about like what
I do or what I've been doing for the
last year is roughly looking at chat
data which is just as horrible as the
medical text that the bureau showed us
it has emojis and crappy spelling and
the guys that are writing it are more
interested in making money than like
actually writing proper English and then
we need to extract stuff from this so
one of the solutions we came up with was
we're going to work at the character
level instead of the word level and this
has a really big plus in that it solved
all those terrible problems and the
really big - which is it makes your
sequence like five or six times longer
so the amount of processing you need to
do is longer there is Explo and I'm very
impatient and so I started looking for
solutions and then this is what this
talks about so now the next slide that
you're not saying is the punchline okay
so the punchline for this whole talk is
and my handwriting is terrible please
excuse me but convolutions okay are fast
okay and if you take away one thing from
this whole talk is that using
convolution will usually be much faster
than using what we usually use in text
and deep learning which is the RNN okay
so I'll define all these terms if I'm
talking a bit of Chinese or like I'll
eventually go down the firing but kind
of what why is fast important so fast is
always nice for the user but in kind of
deep learning machine learning we have
two places where speed is really
important one is when we're in rating
right when we're doing research if we
can run our pipeline in Oh an hour
instead of a day that's really nice
because we can iterate much faster and
we can reach results or find
the result things or just be more
creative because things are going much
faster third thing is in production
right if you take a big model and it's
really heavy and it's doing tons of
compute and you need a big GPU or a
cluster that's just expensive to put in
production right so you need to get
these big Amazon machines or you need to
buy the hardware locally and you need to
make sure everything's configured and
it's a big pain in the butt so it's much
nicer if you can take a model and just
dump it on the simple quad core machine
with basic Rams like something dumb and
commodity and run with that it just
mixing with cheaper to put in production
and easier and to guarantee certain
SFA's so kind of the nice thing about
the slide that you're not seeing is the
you know there's this famous Venn
diagram that's like a right good I don't
know if you can see this a cheap right
and fast and you know they always say
it's like the cap theorem good cheap
fast chews - so my claim here so-called
is that with convolutions you can get
good I mean you'll get results that are
pretty good for most tasks you'll get
cheap in terms of the amount of effort
you need to put in and the hardware that
you need to use to deploy it in
production and you'll get fast these
things are really [ __ ] fast which is
awesome pardon my french and great so
what are we going to cover today and
I'll briefly just go over like common
tasks in NLP and again I wish I had my
slides but for mine and
we'll go over like what does the
convolution look like what the hell is
this thing and then a bit of technical
requirements or like anything any system
we're working with text kind of what we
want from it and yeah and we'll go from
there but let me stop here for a moment
and let's make this a bit more
interactive so raise your hands if you
if you want to know what an RNN is
wonderful okay raise your hand if you've
put it tensorflow in production before
okay good so an even mix so I can't
focus on this with that Hey great and so
it's just this I'm going to talk and if
you guys have questions in the middle
raise your hands and I'll repeat them
right I know everything I want to say if
it's not clear to you stop me and ask so
that we're all on the same page okay
let's go so things we want to do an NLP
okay so one of the one of the I think
one of the big things that we got last
year was translation right Google
published this amazing system where like
it can translate from a bunch of
languages and they trained it to do like
English to Chinese and Chinese to Korean
and then kind of magically they got a
system that can do English to Korean so
that's a really really big breakthrough
right it's been one of the big problems
in NLP and it opens up the bunch of
things other stuff we want to do speech
recognition right so we all talk to our
phone now and go like Siri you know
where's my lunch here okay Google
whatever and so that's like that's huge
that's something new and it's in the
domain of language processing a lot of
times you want to sentiment analysis
right so we want to understand you know
people talking about a particular socket
do you think it's going to go up whether
people like this product or people
talking trash about me on social media
so all that is taking text and somehow
trying to reduce it into a positive or
negative right yeah what else we want to
so I don't know dependency parsing is
boring and I prepared other pictures but
you can all imagine sorry we all have
well text right we all use what's up or
a facebook Messenger whatever and has
this terrible autocomplete Oh
okay all right
amazing all right so another thing wait
well why would laughing they put
something there I shouldn't have great
okay so as I was saying right so we have
obvious oh no I would rather than my
girlfriend I love you and she'll write
back totally over you and then oh [ __ ]
that's the autocomplete [ __ ] it up
right and the thing is what was it
trying to do right wait if you think
about what our system doing this is
going to be on YouTube wonderful okay so
what is this autocomplete trying to do
right it's looking at the sequence of
characters I input it and it's trying to
predict what's the most logical thing
that I'm about to say so that I don't
have to write it if it was smart it
would look at the context I would say
the girlfriend says I love you I totally
over you is not the right answer almost
in any context and so this is a big sale
and why is this stuff hard right if you
think I like English technically or
language in general it has rules we said
them in school there's grammar and
there's no spelling and like the things
make sense but they're ambiguous they
get really complicated really fast and
it's hard to map them out of
rhythmically but that doesn't even
matter because in reality no one follows
the rules right I've probably made a
hundred grammatical mistakes since I've
started this talk so even if we map the
rules perfectly they're just not
relevant to natural language because we
don't follow them they don't matter and
finally all data is dirty so I think
Miro made a good place to point up but
you know we always like video it's dirty
if it's text people are doing spelling
mistakes and whatnot so it's hard to
trust it and but as NLP rotators we want
to do all these things in text ways us
all those problems right it's not an
excuse to not solving the problem it's
just another challenge we need to get
through don't do that
okay so now
let's get into the bread and butter of
things okay convolution so who here
knows what a convolution is tell me out
oh this is wonderful okay so most of you
and so for those basically think of the
convolution is like a sliding window
it's like an Engram right so I'm looking
at I want to look at say is I think I
have three words here love my new right
so that's like a convolution of would
three right I'm looking at three words
at a time and I'm going to slide this
box over kind of to the next three words
and the next three words and then each
time I'm convolving I'm doing this
operation okay so what it is convolving
if you think about it like we can
represent words in all sorts of ways and
in this case we're representing them as
word vectors so like we're Tyvek and
glove and all that stuff right and then
it you get exactly this you get this
kind of box where the x-axis is the
words and the y-axis is all the
different the embedding embedding
dimensions so I don't know well embedded
the 50 dimensions or 300 dimensions
we'll go over that and then each time
we're going to take this convolution
singing and it's going to look over all
the vectors from the three words and
kind of do some linear operation on them
and combine them and reduce them into a
single a single a single number right
and then when we slide over when we go
from love my new iPhone I don't know my
new iPhone then we'll fill in this box
and then when we go one more to the
right we'll fill in this box right
interesting with a number and the car we
use the same so the convoluted saying is
this blue thing this is a sequence of
numbers it's the linear operator so
basically it's a matrix right and when
we're learning and deep learning what
we're learning is the numbers inside of
the blue thing and then we keep on using
them again and again as we slide over
our input text and again we slide over
we fill this guy in here with a bunch of
different numbers over the same filter
but the thing is we want more than once
right so that busy learning a feature
for every every Engram every three or
four whatever we define but what we can
do quite easily is just do this again
and again and again and again with a
bunch of different filters with
different matrices that we're learning
and that's what you're seeing kind of
stacked back here so each one of these
kind of corresponds to each one of these
columns corresponds to a different set
of features that I learned over the same
words so I can keep generating this kind
of a deeper and deeper
richer and richer sets of features over
my same my same inputs
that's convolution does that make sense
no good come to me later because you're
the only one and all right so if we if
we think in general of an NLP system
like when we're looking at text we have
two requirements that we want out of it
what is it can handle arbitrary input
links right so if I say hi I'm Tao
that's a sentence with three words and
say hi I'm Thailand I just came here
from tel-aviv and now I'm looking for an
apartment in Berlin then I didn't count
but that's many more words but we want
our system to be able to take the short
sentence and the long sentence and be
able to hold them both okay and at the
classical way we do this is what's the
bag of words approach right where we
just count words basically and then we
kind of had this big table this word
appeared this word didn't appear but
that doesn't give us anything about the
relationships with the words so the
second the second thing we want from any
NLP system is to be able to capture
dependencies at local scale at different
scales right so from saying hi I'm tau
so you want to know that I am and I are
referring to me and if I'm look talking
at this very long sentence and at the
end when is it when I said Berlin before
you want to know that the Berlin is
somehow referring to the I that is tau
that is looking for something right so
there within any given piece of text
that's arbitrary long their dependencies
at different scales and we want to be
able to capture most of it so I'm sure
that didn't make too much sense so let
me give you an example okay so this is a
this is a cool picture from a open a I
open a I is the research group in the
San Francisco and they did they built
this crazy Network right and all they
had to do they said it Amazon reviews
and so every time they gave it one
character from the review and the acid
to predict the next character and then
they give it in one character in the
review and they access to predict the
next character and they train this thing
on all the Amazon reviews they could get
their hands on and they ran for like a
month on the billion GPUs and crazy
sizes and memory like something nuts and
then is it hey can we like actually
learn sentiment from this right so once
we run this thing on a review we get to
some sort of vector we'll talk about
that more in a minute and can we predict
sentiment from it and it turns out that
[ __ ] we can and we can even do it at the
character level so this this particular
review is interesting because it's
talking about a movie adaptation - for a
book so in the beginning she's like this
is one of Crichton's best books okay and
we'll see best book and every one of us
just like the algorithm is going to say
oh my god sentiment is amazing and then
the writer keeps on going and saying
that how great the book is but how
terrible the film is and how like it did
a really really bad job at adapting but
then what's really amazing is down here
if you look alright so it says the book
is really really good now any kind of
classical NOP system that I that I know
we'll see really really good and it's
going to shout out sentiment super
positive right but this guy didn't write
it somehow managed to remember that even
though the really really good is talking
about the book the object of the
sentence isn't the book it's the film
and so the sentiment the sentiment
didn't jump up and that's kind of an
example of a very long term dependencies
that multiple scales within a within a
text that makes sense
great it's it true don't you think that
I'd just learned that book and really
really good in the sentence is just a
bad thing to say in an Amazon review
about the movie soothing sit again a
really really good book is generally a
bad thing to say when talking about a
movie it could be but then it still
knows that it's talking about a movie so
right it captured that but it still
remembers I'm talking about a movie even
though that's like we recognize the
movie three sentences ago and that's the
long term dependency okay okay
yeah all right so some of you before
said you'd like to know a bit about RNA
so let's do that and okay so RN and
recurrent neural networks and their
modification those times either become
like the [ __ ] for and for deep learning
on text right so all of our cutting-edge
stuff in translation and speech
recognition and sentiment in word
imputation and whatever like NLP tasks
you have on a sequence you know the
state-of-the-art solution and the stuff
that's in production that we're all
using on our phones l STM's or RN ends
okay so basically what they do
so the RN is this box a right and we
feed it inputs or don't do that help me
you live of this if someone wants to
come and help me make it nicer that's
great it's not don't and all right so we
have we have this box a and what a does
is we feed it an input like hi
I go away hi yeah so hi I am towel right
and we fit into this box a and every
time we feed it again put it gives us an
output that's great but the beauty of
this thing a is that it's a state
machine right so when I feed it hi it
remembers that it saw hi and when it
gives me the output for the next word I
then it's gonna the output is going to
be conditioned not just on the input I
gave it I but also on everything else
that it saw before okay so if I give it
a really long sentence or a full
paragraph like we saw that it's going to
condition every output even 3,000 or
4,000 words down on the previous input
set it saw and so and in that sense it's
very much a state machine but what's
kind of nice about it is that it's a
distributed state machine so instead of
having like a finite list of states in
the transition and the you know a
discrete transition system it's all
distributed right it so it's very soft
and we can go to subtle directions and
it's very hard to interpret but it
allows for a very rich expression of
them of
of anything right of state and let's
take a quick look at how this thing
looks in Python so this is this is the
actual input implementation for a
recurrent neural network you can
copy/paste this stuff like I did and run
it and you'll have something that will
actually do the inference that it still
doesn't learn but it goes forward right
so basically they are and it has three
three pieces that learn that like we're
training so it has a matrix that learns
the transition from hidden state to
hidden state so like my internal stage
now as I saw nothing I saw the word I
and there's a certain transition from my
first day to my next site how do I
transition given one input how do I
transition how does it influence my own
State
alright that's another matrix and
finally given the state that I'm in
where my box a is in what output should
I put out okay and these are the three
these are the three parameters that the
RNN is learning and it of course
contains a hidden state and then at
every step every time we go go away
every time we give it an input X it
takes the dot product the matrix product
between this vector of our input and our
transition matrix it adds it to the dot
product of the our state and the
transition matrix four states it applies
a non-linearity and that's it and that's
our that's our new state okay and then
it for the output we just take our new
state we use the other matrix that we
have and that's the that's the that's
the output right we that's it
that's what it does so I don't know if
that sounded simple or not if you spend
a few minutes of the code and it is
alright so what's nice about this thing
it takes input which is great it
arbitrarily as long as we want all right
we can do I am Talon that will work here
and we can put in a book and that'll
work here and it captures long term
dependencies exactly what we want it
great and then we can do things that are
crazy so this is like an example of the
how we originally did translation with
our NS so the first the first paper
sequence the sequence learning by Ilya
sutskever I think it was in like 2014 he
said all right we'll take an input in
English we'll run the whole thing and
then we'll
take it we'll take this vector H and
we'll just dump it into a new RN n and
we'll have it will let it out put
something feed it back into it I'll put
something feed it back into it and
that's how we're going to translate and
he showed well should the stuff works
better than anything we've ever had
before and then things got crazy quite
quickly so they're like well we're here
we're only going from left to right but
sometimes we also want to have the
context at the end of the sentence
influenced the beginning so let's set up
something like this that goes left to
right and another one that goes right to
left and we'll stack them together and
then we can get the context from both
sides and then I'm going to skip this
one but it gets pretty bad and great oh
thank you and so remember a few minutes
ago I told you that L STM's or RN n to
the state of the art and everything
we're doing an NLP right this is what we
have in production so why do we even
want to talk about convolution all right
if we have this great solution and
here's one answer for you all right so
this is the Mallory the first guy that
climbed the Everest and why did he climb
the Everest and she said it was there
and it's not just a smartass funny
answer I think that you know the world
of deep learning machine learning digits
really exploding now and there are a lot
of new things to play around with and a
lot of especially if it's our job we
have the luxury of getting to explore
new and interesting things and once in a
while you know a lot of times it's going
to be a time kind of wasted or without
much ROI but once in a while you'll
stumble upon something that's really
interesting a really practical it really
helps for work really helps you
understand what you're doing and I think
for just for that reason it's very
worthwhile to pursue these things that
are maybe not intuitive not common but
if that doesn't convince you then the
more important fact is that convolutions
are just really really fast and data
efficient and the reason they're really
really fast is that they work in
parallel as opposed to rnns that work
sequentially so what do I mean I'll go
back for a second so look here right we
can't process if this is like I am tau
then this thing go away all right so if
that's I am tau so we can't process tau
right before we process - I am so we're
working sequentially here there's no
oralism and we definitely don't get to
leverage the the kind of inherent
parallelism GPUs which is what
everyone's talking about there's a very
big bottleneck conversely with with
convolutions so we can run this filter
and the filter after it and the filter
after it at the same time all right so
we can because there's no dependence
between them they're just these really
small tiny operations and it just so
happens that GPUs are very very good at
running these kinds of computations in
parallel and just for that reason you
get this tremendous speed up that's
because in this case the the computation
runs in parallel and in our end the
computation is sequential it's a big
deal a great
and so the work and problem make better
use which is another nice feature so I
showed you a few minutes ago that the RN
and if we want to take the the context
that's coming from the end of the
sentence like hi I am tile and you want
to know that you want to somehow output
something about high that takes time to
account we need to make a pass from left
to right and a pass from right to left
so we have to double our computations to
get there kind of to get the both sides
of the sentence conversely convolutions
will look about in the min they work
hierarchically so we'll do one layer of
convolutions of trigrams and then we'll
do another layer of convolutions on top
of that and on top of that and on top of
that and each layer will kind of look at
more and more of the of the input but it
have some view of all of it and that's
going to give this kind of a
hierarchical understanding of our inputs
and I'll show you an example that in a
moment
and just to tell you that the I'm not
making this stuff up and that you know
someone certified kind of it says the
same so Facebook published an article
about a month ago where they showed that
they got an improvement 1.5 blue
improvement over a very well performing
a lsdm base translation system and their
thing is nine times faster than the
baseline bit compared to two right and
Google just published an article like
that as well and so this is stuff it's
not just me saying it great
I am going to skip this part does anyone
have a strong desire to see how to write
the code for a convolution yes
excuse me first of all that's not true
and second I'm going to show you how to
get over that okay so the man the man
makes a point okay so I have ten minutes
Bokke all right so let's do let's skip
it and and whoever buys me a beer I'll
show them how to do it yeah but just
just edit it there is now one
dimensional convolutions and tensorflow
and here's how to if you need to do
other operations that aren't supported
one day so the slides that are on github
have the way to do it and get around it
and that's great but the here's I think
the most important conceptual thing that
I want to pass on okay so there are two
there are two kind of parallel concepts
when we talk about convolutions one is
receptive fields and one is hierarchy
okay so let's start with hierarchy and
let's look at the example of images
right so Facebook is really creepy they
always know that it's me when I put up
my picture right there because they can
do facial recognition and how do they do
that stuff right so they get an image
and they do these layers of convolutions
on them and the first layer you some of
you probably seen this learns like
really basic features like little edges
and curves and kind of differences in
the brightness or whatever and then the
next layer looks at a bunch of these
guys together and it starts to put
together like more advanced shapes like
an eye and nose and mouth whatever and
then the next layer on top of that it's
looking at noses and eyes and whatever
and eventually it's putting together a
whole face and from that face then it
can figure out this is Todd this is not
Tao hot dogs not hot dog and stuff like
that right but you think about it like
how many pixels are involved in seeing a
face or how many of these guys are
involved in seeing a face so a lot so
when we say receptive field what we're
talking is that the final layer in the
convolutional Network so maybe this guy
here how many of the original input
pixels or in our world of text how many
of the original words or characters is
it able to see that's the receptive
field okay and as we so we can make the
receptive field bigger in a few ways we
can make the convolution at each step
wider right before I show you back step
three but we could do steps
or step 150 and their trade-offs right
will pay a big performance will pay a
computational cost but it'll work or we
can do what we're doing here and we can
kind of stack things up so if you look
at like hey this guy is seeing yeah this
guy's seeing two inputs right and then
this big guy is seeing two A's okay and
EJ is seeing two inputs one of them is
shared so HB has a receptive field of
three and then we could keep going and
get the receptive field of five and ten
and twenty we can just keep on stacking
them and this is kind of important so I
want everyone to take a moment and tell
me what you think of this sentence
no one really huh okay so I'm gonna
point out - it's not a question right
there's a period here okay so it's not
what has for us like it's not Adams what
has four letters one two three four
sometimes has nine letters this right
never has five letters great and this is
a valid intersects but it confuses the
hell out of us because we read the word
what when we assume it's a question even
though we have a period at the very end
of it that completely changes the
meaning of the entire sentence and so in
the kind of point is when we think about
a offices people or or a system we want
to be able to get everything into the
receptive field so a lot of times we
can't we can't answer the question
before we saw the entire input and we
can't say something about the first word
or the first character before we we see
the last one because it can change the
entire meaning of everything okay so
when I'm talking about receptive fields
and why they're important because in
text we always in every - every time
I've worked off text I've always wanted
to get the max the receptive field as
big as I possibly can how much time do I
have left all right well I'm gonna I'm
going to run through this okay so the
thing is that it's really hard to make
the receptive field dig okay it's just
not trivial the trivial way is to kind
of stack the convolutions one layer on
top of another layer and intuitively
this should work but the thing is right
so when you go forward when you make the
inference and you pass it through all
these layers then it does work right
like there's no problem but on the way
back when you're learning when you're
doing back propagation keep learning or
whatever it is and the signal needs to
come back through these layers right and
at every step if you've got a hundred
layers that one forward the gradient the
signal the way the correcting has to go
back 100 layers and a lot of times in
those 100 layers it's going to end up
getting multiplied by really small
numbers and if you take a lot of small
numbers you multiply them by each other
you're gonna get zero and then you're
going to feel like that because when you
get zero in your gradients then you're
now
not going to learn anything you're just
going to run for three days and
nothing's going to happen and again
you'll feel like that and swear to God
that felt like that but there are two
solutions and I'm going to really
quickly run through one of them with you
and I like both of them but the one
we'll talk about in a second as I've had
so much successful fit recently that the
I love it so much and I highly recommend
you all the embrace it and so what we're
going to talk about is residual
connections and I'll explain that in a
second and there's another cool trick
called dilated convolutions which is if
any of you saw like wavenet bite net
like these google papers where they like
learn to play the piano or generate the
crazy sounds that use that trick but
we're not going to talk about it so
let's go right into residual connections
thank you
all right and so here's this stick right
we said with convolution if we naively
stack them then the system like the
signal has this is like a stacked
convolution all right each one of these
colors are there and in the traditional
way though means like connection is a
straight line between them right so the
obvious thing to do is kind of to put a
line some sort of way for the signal to
go directly from the first layer to the
last layer from every layer in between
right and there are a few ways to do
this 2016 was like the big year of
residual connections right and the
coolest and the one I like the most is a
it comes from a paper called dense net
and basically what they say was you take
the output of your first layer of your
layer and then you run it from account
you run through a convolution and you
concatenate the two outputs so I don't
know if that made sense luckily I have a
picture now that we have this thing
right so we start with our initial text
we run a convolution on it maybe we had
the initial representation of the text
with like each word was a
three-dimensional vector right and then
we ran a convolution on it and we got 24
we the output was a 24 dimensional
vector
so we start with that now we have our 24
dimensional parameters we run another
convolution this time that outputs 12
and now instead of just keeping those
last 12 where we're going to do is
concatenate them so on our next step
we're not going to have 24 we're not
going
have 12 we're going to have 36 we're
going to have to 24 from the previous
step and the 12 we just calculated and
that gives us this first line here right
the 24 that we just took out and the 12
that we calculated and then we can do
that again all right well calculate
another 12 features and instead of just
keeping them we'll concatenate them and
again with just and then we get 48 and
what this does is give us a direct
connection
so our gradients can always travel
directly but it also gives us something
else that's really nice right so
tradition when we use convolutions and
we take just the upper layer we have a
view of the original input but we it's
kind of fuzzy because we're looking at
all these different abstractions at
women but this way we are also
preserving every abstraction every layer
together so we can look at directly the
original input we can look at like it's
trigram we can look at the trigram of
the trigram etc etc and so I'll give you
I think this is my last slide so just
kind of for my personal experience and
how nice this has been for me so I did I
put a system recently in production work
I built it originally with an LS TM
eventually with convolutions and we got
to the point where we got equal results
with both systems but to cut the Alice
team system took two days to Train I had
a million parameters in it and was slow
in production and the convolutional
system had 80,000 parameters instead of
a million and will train in about an
hour and so that was a great success and
essentially based on this architecture
and that's it thank you
you